i felt it coming
[ __ ] it let's go with there
i'm crying internally right now
oh this is like a truth
oh we'll pick another ask anyway
um that's boring i'm just gonna go
through all of these
should i change it to truth
oh
i like this one oh god
that means my life is over first who is
your least favorite ex
oh in her head she said that [ __ ]
who is it
anthony
okay call your least favorite ex to ask
them out
no problem
hello
hello
hey
how have you been
i've been great how about you
i've been all right
um
i've been thinking a lot lately
and honestly like i i realized like i
just really miss you
and i don't know like
maybe shit's been tough i don't know i
just really miss you and
i feel like we haven't talked in forever
huh
yeah are you there
i am dead
what's something you made this do you
think
what
um what kind of made you come to that
conclusion
i don't know i feel like i just looked
back and i feel like we have a lot of
good memories i mean like [ __ ] was tough
to be fair but i feel like we were
really young
and i don't know things are different
now
and i was just really hoping that like
we could meet up sometime soon and just
talk
just talk
[Music]
that's crazy i never thought you'd be
the type to like you know be tied down
to one woman that's crazy
what about a threesome though
why is it n
why is it n
is it because i would find her
unattractive or is it because
what
no are you
wouldn't sure it wouldn't happen
damn that's a damn shame
yeah sorry i can't really
do anything like that that's not what
okay
it sounds like you're outside where you
going
[Music]
i'm actually gonna go grab some food
you know four or five months of
dieting and [ __ ]
okay
so you still wrestling and all that
okay
i mean is your girl giving you that good
head because i could change
[Music]
well
in that case i'm very proud of you for
being loyal
you kind of have to be boy you don't
have to do anything that you don't want
to
well i do want to do that and i want to
do that
i want to
put somebody
truly enjoyed being with she got me out
of a very dark place that i was
in my life i got you out of a dark place
did you yeah i did
i i did so much for you and all you did
was break my heart weekly but i'm still
here
actually the thing is like by the time
your voice i can't tell from that
[ __ ] around me or not
that's i'm sorry i'm just autistic you
can't tell us all right
oh my gosh
hey listen it's all right i'm gonna text
you later if anything all right
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't
i can't hear you
i just hung up that's it that was an